good evening Fernando welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored in the five days since
allegations about Russell Brand were
made public he's been excommunicated
he's becoming a chilling case study on
guilty until proven innocent and how can
anyone now lose everything without any
due process at all as of today it's been
shockingly cheered on by the British
Parliament first brand was dropped by
his management companies live shows were
postponed his book deal with shelved
Netflix channel 400 BBC have begun
quietly dropping his content but in
recent years brand hasn't relied on any
of those platforms for influence he
makes his money doing this
so how is this fire being used what's
the truth about it and why are there so
many conspiracy theories mainstream
media and state interests continually
use legitimate tragedies in an
opportunistic way there's a little
Wrinkle in this where people were trying
to set Ukraine up so that foreign
investment opportunities would be
presented is this in order to reverse
climate change and feed the world or is
or is it so that
selling it can be patented and
controlled by Bill Gates social
catastrophes that ruin most people's
lives are beneficial to financial Elites
Wars that ruin the lives of Ukrainian
and Russian people are beneficial to the
weapons manufacturing industry
now I personally think some of what
Russell Brown says is complete nonsense
and other stuff I agree with he's got
every right to say though what he wants
and he has also followers who love what
he says there's six and a half million
subscribers on his YouTube channel alone
the Google own company though is now
scriptures account of the ability to
make money at least for him he can still
post videos he just can't take his cut
now in a citizen development an arm of
the British State he's pressing other
platforms to do the same Dane Carolyn
Caroline dinage the chair of the culture
media and Sport committee is written to
X formerly Twitter Tick Tock and Rumble
these alternative platforms where brand
has a big following asking them to drop
it we are concerned that he may be able
to profit from his content on the
platform she said we will be grateful if
you could confirm whether Mr Brown is
able to monetize his content if so we'd
like to know whether you intend to join
YouTube into spending Mr Brown's ability
to earn money now Russell Brand is
accused of very serious things rape and
sexual abuse their grave allegations
reported meticulously by exemplary
journalism at dispatches Channel 4 and
the Sunday Times but they remain at the
moment accusations these are claims by
people by people who remained Anonymous
I think the conspiracy theories about an
establishment attack to crush the
dissenting voice are hogwash but I can't
think of a better way to Fan those
conspiracy flames and for a
parliamentary committee to intervene
like this as more people make their
living online we should be extremely
concerned about the ability of tech
companies to choose who gets to do that
and in a liberal democracy no one should
have more respect for due process than
Parliament it's not about taking sides
on Russell Brand if he's guilty he
deserves a punishment every bit is
severe as the alleged crimes he
committed but trial by MPS or trial by
Silicon Valley seems to me dangerous and
wrong
well to discuss I'm joined by daily wire
host Michael Knowles in America Michael
there are lots of strands to this
Russell Brand Story
but let's focus on one today which is
this what appears to be an extraordinary
overreach by the British Parliament
where the the chair of the select
committee has written to all these tech
companies demanding effectively that
they financially cancel Russell Brand
over allegations what is your reaction
to this
I'm glad to see that Rumble responded to
Parliament and said uh no we're not
going to cancel someone who hasn't had
due process of law based on mere
accusations without a conviction that's
really great it's unfortunate however
that YouTube didn't need any nudging
from Parliament YouTube decided to
demonetize Russell Brand right away
based on what based on some reporting of
decades-old allegations which may or may
not be true I don't know Russell Brand
has has been pretty open about having
been a derelict and a degenerate for a
long period of time in his life but this
is a very deeply concerning thing
because it's not just a matter of our
institutions turning a little bit
oppressive it's not just a matter of the
internet becoming less free with with
YouTube clamping down it's a matter of
our whole society do we have a free
Society or not well if we don't have due
process of law then we can't make any
claim to being a free Society any longer
right I mean I I don't happen to think
as many people seem to to judging my
social media there's been some
deliberate orchestrated mainstream media
attempt to gag and silence Russell Brand
so for what is worth I don't think that
is what's happened here I think this is
actually a SP a spillover from the me
too and time's up campaigns I think
they've been working on it for four
years some of these journalists and they
finally think they have enough to
publish these allegations against
Russell Brown and that's fine I read the
journalism with my former newspaper hat
on editor hat on I thought the the
journalism was perfectly well executed
but and it's a very important but it
they remain allegations and it seems to
me what's happening here is that the
British Parliament is now joining in in
a concerted effort by a number of
entities to effectively be judged and
jury on Russell Brand to preemptively
convict him of these allegations and to
punish him now that just seems to me on
every level that is that should not be
happening
this is a blurring of Institutions that
we've seen build up for years now you
see this especially on campuses if there
is a claim of sexual impropriety on
campus what happens do the students go
to the police and then there's a trial
over rape no what happens is a bunch of
professors get together in a committee
and they hold a kangaroo court and they
will they will be judged during
executioner they'll expel the student
without any due process of law and in
recent years we've seen that a number of
these have turned out to be hoaxes well
how did they get it so wrong because
professors are not supposed to be the
ones who are who are exercising the law
they're not they're not law enforcement
officers in the same way that Parliament
here is not supposed to be conducting
the trial certainly not Parliament and
the media put together and YouTube and
Rumble are not supposed to be enforcing
the law to your point peers I don't
think that there's a cabal of people in
a smoky back room somewhere saying we've
got to go get brand but it is convenient
that amid all of these sexual debauchery
that typifies Hollywood which we call
Gamora by the Sea over here you know
everybody virtually is involved in it
the people that tend to be held to
account even decades later are people
who speak out and so you look at someone
like Bill Cosby I have no doubt that
Bill Cosby did all sorts of nasty things
some of which may have been illegal but
I think that the reason the
establishment stopped liking Bill Cosby
is because he said things that were
Politically Incorrect and politically
conservative and the same thing goes for
Russell Brandt here the longer the the
time between the alleged crimes and the
consequences for those crimes the more
skeptical I am about the people who are
suddenly moved to prosecute yeah I mean
there's no doubt also that the way that
uh certain strands of the media covering
the Russell Brand Scandal is very
interesting because they've all pivoted
on their positions depending on how he's
been perceived with his own opinions in
other words when he was a left-wing
darling a few years ago he was sitting
in on the guardian editorial conferences
for example next to the editor he was a
highly prized columnist there for a
number of years he guest edited the new
States from the left-wing publication
you know he was appearing on stage with
big left-wing fire Brands like Owen
Jones and so on and it goes on and on
and on and he was lauded despite his
open bragging about his sort of pretty
depraved sexual activity he did it to me
in a GQ interview talking about you know
just a phenomenal number of women he was
having sex with and how he would look
for good targets his words not mine and
so on very kind of Hunter language which
today I suspect someone made a good
point actually if social media had
existed when that interview appeared
he'd been onto Pieces by social media
and he might have concentrated his mind
and he might have avoided getting
himself into the problems that that came
later and what he's experiencing now but
with also no social media so this stuff
would appear but nobody moved to cancer
Russell Brand then none of these
left-wing organizations thought this was
only reprehensible now a lot of the same
people because he's now seen as a sort
of alt-right kind of character you know
really adopted by the conservatives now
a lot of people on the left who's
happily saluted and celebrated him
knowing what he was admitting in public
about his activities then now
revisionously going back and feigning in
my view moral outrage over what he was
admitting to then I don't think you can
do that
certainly people are comparing this to a
Soviet show trial to a kangaroo court
where where the people are convicted
before any evidence is presented and I
think that's a good analogy because I
think it explains why these guys get off
the hook for all of their improprieties
for so long and that's so that people
have compromise on them you know the so
that they put themselves in compromising
positions and they get away with it
until they stop Towing the party line
and then all of a sudden it becomes a
political attack you see even in the
time story that came out the the the big
transgression here seems to have been
more political than sexual because the
women say they were only motivated to
speak out when they were contacted by
journalists it's it's not as though they
ran to law enforcement it's not as
though they penned an essay on sub stack
or medium or something like that this
was a decision that was made within the
media it's obviously a political
decision because newspaper editors are
political figures and the way that we
can underscore that is just as soon as
the story came out already the political
figures are getting involved up to and
including Parliament yeah and you see I
mean you see a lot of double standard I
think in for example the way that Donald
Trump has been treated over his alleged
misdemeanors and the way uh Joe Biden
has over the hunter Biden laptop Scandal
and so on completely different set of
Standards you know when Trump for
example is found with a classified
documents it's the worst thing of all
time and it's pretty serious but when
they're finding Joe Biden's garage you
know the same journalists who've been so
incensed by Trump's uh keeping these
documents almost don't want to don't
want to acknowledge that Biden's done
the same thing
well don't forget peers they first tried
to impeach Donald Trump for colluding
with the Russians and then that
investigation the Mueller investigation
went absolutely nowhere so they flipped
and decided they were going to impeach
Donald Trump for colluding with the
ukrainians and the subject was that
Donald Trump had some kind of untoward
improper phone call with the leader of
Ukraine and the Supreme irony here is
while Donald Trump had a perfectly fine
phone call we now know for a fact that
Joe Biden did exert extreme political
pressure on Ukraine in fact he set up
phone calls with the president of
Ukraine under pseudonym pseudonyms
through which he was involved in his
son's crooked business deals
some was earning millions of dollars
sitting on the board of Ukrainian and
company for which he had
he had a lutely zero experience I mean
it's a more blatant form of corruption
when your father's vice president with
specific interest in Ukraine it's hard
to imagine
Joe Biden's attorney general just came
out yesterday Merrick Garland and he
said with a straight face you got to
give him credit for being a supreme
actor he said that there's only one
system of justice in the United States
not two tiers of Justice at the same
time he's ducking questions about the
FBI targeting Catholics that the FBI
targeting parents and then the the most
farcical aspect of it all which is that
for the first time in American history a
former president is being indicted the
leader of the opposition is currently
being indicted meanwhile you've got far
more evidence of far more egregious
crimes from the sitting president of the
United States and what do they do they
slap the sun Hunter Biden with no more
than a minor gun charge of all the
crimes that we've seen this guy commit
on terabytes on his computer they hit
him on the gun charge the one crime that
doesn't implicate his father yeah total
corruption an astonishing coincidence
you might not think uh great to talk to
you Michael thank you very much
beers great to be with you thanks for
having me